folks if you want to see me live we are
at Coachella tonight no one's coming to
that because it's [ __ ] storming and
it's in the middle of nowhere and it's
January but then where Reno Nevada
Saturday January 21st then we are in
Oxnard California my favorite place
Oxnard January 27 28 to 29th Raleigh
North Carolina the 9th through the 11th
Tucson Arizona on the 16th of February
Phoenix Arizona the 17th through the
19th of February Monterey California the
23rd if it still exists Vancouver Canada
on the 24th nap at California on the
25th one of my favorites Palm Beach
Florida the 9th through the 11th of
March Englewood New Jersey April 13th
Huntington New York at the Paramount the
14th New Brunswick New Jersey the 15th
and um Sunday April 16th Huntington New
York ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
Tim Dillon show from Storm ravaged
California we bring you a message right
now from the leader of California our
leader we bring you a message from her
she's in distress
don't know here
what you don't know is uh Alan is doing
this with her mind
she's making these Waters Rage with her
mind this is a trick she does something
that's actually rather impressive she's
actually creating all these conditions
uh herself and then standing outside she
uploaded this video uh in Montecito many
of the uh Montecito is an area two hours
north of California I'm sorry uh Los
Angeles uh in the Santa Barbara
Montecito is a very elite uh part of
Santa Barbara where a lot of wealthy
people live like Oprah uh Ellen
Degeneres and Harry and Megan uh were
living there for a period And this is
the area that got hit the hardest now
obviously Los Angeles had some flooding
and there was some some small mudslides
and boulders were on the street and they
closed some roads and uh there are some
issues in people's yards uh where the
you know if you live on a hill sometimes
uh I was talking to my landscaper she
said one uh one of her clients
um part of someone else's yard
um uh fell just went right into that
person's pool so if someone is above you
and they don't have a retaining wall
their Earth slides down into your pool
so my landscaper is figuring figuring
that out Ellen DeGeneres though uh is
upset about this as as you know as a res
a long time resident of Montecito uh
she's out there we'll watch the rest of
this video uh this is some type of
um behind her is a creek
some type of river
uh that is uh flooding what's what's
happening in California now you think
you know someone
um you think you're used to what the
problems could be and
I've lived here on and off for four
years and uh what I've noticed is that
um you know the the population here is
is very very accustomed to fires so too
accustomed to it like you drive down a
highway and it's on fire and no one
cares like people are so comfortable
with fires in this state because they
happen all the time that literally three
houses away will be on fire and people
in their backyard go ah it's there
that's down there we're not gonna go
nuts people will see fire happening in
their neighborhoods and not leave they
won't evacuate because they will
literally tell well for the fire to come
up here would have to go around that
people are so comfortable with flames
and fire
um and droughts we all have been
accustomed to the drought who cares it
doesn't affect anyone there's still
water there's a lot of water you can
shower you can drink bottles of water
everyone has a bottle of water uh nobody
is not hydrated because it is drought we
buy water from Lake Mead feed or from uh
you know wherever we're stealing the
water from wherever we're buying it from
we have water we're not now people keep
saying we have less and less water it's
going to be more of a problem there are
now Governors on the uh how much you can
uh use your sprinkler system so The
Lawns of Beverly Hills and Bel Air God
help us are getting a little brown and a
lot of people have switched out their
grass for Turf because it doesn't need
to be watered and some people are
getting rid of grass in general and
doing a sand kind of rock garden Cactus
thing that looks fine so everybody's
accustomed to droughts everybody's
accustomed to fire people get it [ __ ]
burns down that's okay nobody's really I
mean there are instances where people
burn up in their houses because they're
up until the last minute they're not
convinced they should leave but the one
thing that nobody has really dealt with
here is flooding and and and you know
excess of rain and I don't want to hear
about droughts anymore if we can't use
the rain now people go well we don't
even the water that comes in we don't
even know how to use it they go we don't
know how to use it it's filthy it's we
just gotta you know it's like well the
here's the water for the drought figure
it out you can't in two weeks they're
gonna start talking about a drought
again but this has in in
the positives of this is that the lakes
and the rivers of California their
levels are are higher I don't know what
that means I don't know if it means
we're out of the drought I don't think
it does
so so you get
you get the worst of all worlds whereas
you'll still in a drought but it's
flooding but it's a drought and
I've lived here and I I'll tell you the
weather is never what it's been it's
never sold as you know it's not accurate
whether it's not tropical weather it's
not Florida
um it's cold it's desert it's hot during
the day and cold at night
um it's weirdly overcast in a lot of the
beach communities there's this layer of
Gloom this Oceanic layer uh and if it's
not hot enough it the sun will not
pierce it and it'll just be kind of
Bleak and gray and gloomy it's not what
you think it is here but it's never been
quite this bad this is a new level
of uh bad for California where people
are like you know getting like tragic
shits going on like people are
a kid was like Swept Away
on like I don't even know how that
happens he's like oh like his parents
something tragically happened where he
ended up getting swept I mean this is
like biblical [ __ ] and
um nobody's prepared for this except
Alan who created it let's watch the the
end of her little plea
to our house never flows ever
probably about nine feet up and it's
gonna go another two feet up we have
horses ready to evacuate
be nicer to Mother Nature because Mother
Nature is not happy with us
stay safe everybody
now Ellen brings up a good point that we
need to be nicer to Mother Nature now
get up Ellen's real estate portfolio
because it's very important
to always think about your actions in
relation to the balance of the world
like the navi in Avatar
um so let me just read this uh first
um
first uh sentence here in the article uh
this is uh uh Ellen Degeneres and her
wife Portia de Rossi the title of this
article in architectural digest is
inside Ellen DeGeneres and Portia De
Rossi's endless
real estate portfolio
endless is the word in 2022 alone the
couple purchased four properties and
sold three
and
Ellen has a Ellen's house at Montecito
get get that up because she's got a
mid-century modern in Montecito here's
the thing with Ellen she always makes
really good real estate choices they're
always pretty [ __ ] dope
and they're stunning
and so she's got this house in Montecito
she paid 21 I believe it's 21 million
dollars for it
uh oh sorry the Ellen DeGeneres sells
Bali inspired Montecito property for 33
million I wonder how big it's a 9.3 acre
compound
now let's see how big that is and square
footage if we can find
there's square footage on that
um we know it's 9.3 Acres
I wonder how big it is but
I I don't know what Alan means I
understand when she goes we should be
nicer
to
mother nature but
you know she owns
tens of thousands of square feet of real
estate that needs to be heated and
cooled
all the time I mean this is
you know this is not like she doesn't
own like a bungalow she owns a lot of
proper and I own houses there's nothing
wrong with owning houses not as much big
as hers
but you know it's nice to say
um she's got a 4 000 square foot
property
but this is not there's no way
that that's the one that sold for 33
million I would be shocked
um what does she mean by that be nicer
to Mother Nature I mean it's like a nice
thing to say but I don't know what she
means by that
maybe she knows mother net like maybe
she knows these gods and she has a
personal beef with
uh Mother Nature you know I mean I don't
know it's it's um it's possibly
something that you know is happening in
a realm that we don't know so she's got
you know about 11
000 square feet she's got
um
four bedrooms ten bathrooms and about 11
000 square feet it's the sprawling
property comprising 18 000 square foot
main house and a ten thousand square
foot guest house
um and and so this is um
so this is one of her properties
that we're looking at between the guest
house and the main house about thirty
thousand square feet of real estate that
Ellen has
and God bless I mean but again it's like
you'd you'd be you'd wonder what
being nicer to Mother Nature would mean
if you had 30
000 square feet of real estate for one
of your homes
just one of your homes get up some more
um
examples of how bad this has gotten in
California this has gotten really bad
um kayakers are paddling uh in Santa
Barbara and Madison and with Santa
Barbara's where really wealthy people go
when they're kind of through with LA and
they're bigger than LA and they don't
need to be here they go up to Santa
Barbara and they go up to Montecito and
it's not right that they have to deal
with this to be to be honest with you
it's actually not right because they've
made it out they've gotten out of Los
Angeles or away from the homeless
they're up in their Hamlet they're in
this small little beautiful kind of
country idyllic Coastal Country Town
with the 33 million dollar uh 30 000
square foot home and uh you know it's
ugly they're closing highways people are
dying the death toll of this storm I
think the last time I checked was at 12.
12 people had died in the California
storm
um
and it's not a dignified death 17 are
now dead it's not a dignified death
dying in California in a fire makes
sense dying in a flood is stupid it's
like silly and it's like crazy to even
admit people that that you know are
affected by this don't even want to tell
people how you died
um massive Los Angeles sinkhole swallows
two vehicles but they rescued the
passengers
the Earth is opening up big holes are
opening up in the middle of the street
cars are falling in and how dumb do you
really have to be to fall into a
sinkhole unless you it literally opens
as you're on it but people in this state
are so dumb they might just they're not
paying attention and they literally just
try it's a big hole and they just and
they go right in I don't know if that's
what happened but
um it is unfortunately uh you know led
to death and fatality people are
dropping like flies we've got 17 people
dead
um which is crazy and you know the hope
is that
um you know that this uh rain stops
because the rain doesn't stop La is all
these places these are dirt Hills
they're not really mountains these are
dirt Hills that everybody lives on my
house is on a dirt Hill and if it gets
too wet all the houses slide off the
hills and they slide into the canyon
um and that's not what you'd want
um but that's a little weather update
here and you know we hope play this
Derek took his kayak down a flooded city
Street in Santa Barbara today
but I mean
every year it happens and every year we
us as a community over at melpes tried
to make sure the drains
stay clear so this doesn't happen to
everyone on the street
yeah
sorry but I think I need to get back now
all right well listen You'll Be safe and
take care of yourself it's the end of
the world
all right well this is something you
don't see every day
I don't think I've ever spoken because I
don't think I've ever spoken to someone
who is of a Latino designer
she goes which is strange because I've
lived here for years and she does this
is odd but I felt safe because he was on
a kayak
look at that kayaking down the street it
seems a little fun doesn't it
like it's a little exciting too let's be
honest just a little exciting it's a
little exciting and a little fun
seeing all the and this is what people
this is going to be the double-edged
sword of climate change because although
it is going to kill people and Destroy
things it is going to kind of be a
little fun it's not politics it's
something to talk about that isn't
politics what's going on are you okay
the [ __ ] weather is not everybody's
kind of dealing with it together it kind
of brings people together I don't even
know if I'm against it
because of the of the of the the it it
it it it it it flattens people whether
you're rich or poor you have to deal
with extreme weather and I think that's
something that actually could be a very
unifying thing in our society is as
these incidences of extreme weather
become more frequent people are actually
going to become closer you know we've
had a very divided couple of years it's
very divisive politically culturally but
you know no one's talking about drag
queen Story Hour now because
everything's flooded and people are
losing everything and I gotta be honest
with you I think there's sort of
something nice about it this might this
next era which is going to be 30 to 50
years of biblical fires and floods maybe
actually lovely
like it may actually be so nice because
nobody's going to be fighting about
[ __ ]
if we're all kind of and everyone's
gonna kind of move around the country
trying to outsmart the disasters all the
real estate shows it's kind of going to
be fun to see like people are gonna go
from the mountains they're going to get
burned out of the mountains and they're
going to go to the the low-lying areas
and then they're going to get flooded
out and then they're gonna go to the
Plains and I mean it's gonna be fun to
kind of watch people
migrate from disaster to disaster
building different properties to
withstand the coming revenge of the
Earth
I mean I don't want a lot of people to
die I'm not a big fan of mass death many
of you who watch your show know that
I've never been pro-mass death I don't
think everyone can live
but I don't think that
everyone should dial at once I like a
trickling a slow trickling but to me
something like this it's nice to see
Alan in front of the overflowing river
it makes you feel like we're all one
right I think it's a little nice to see
a raging River she's a little nervous
you go all the money she's got all the
property she's got she's still subject
to the same Natural Forces
that we all are
so it you know if if if a celebrity were
to kind of get it
if a celeb yeah you see in her eyes
she's a little bit like hey what's up
now
you know
she is gonna be fine she's gonna be safe
she can be airlifted out but is it's
nice to see
people of means a little panicked all
the movies that are coming out now
whether it's triangle of sadness or the
menu these are great movies that talk
about class everybody wants to hit
wealthy people
Beverly Hills Bentley everybody wants
Louis Vuitton everybody pull up
everybody wants the wealthy to die
everyone wants a wealthy to die now this
is a fact
and seeing these if if if if if
we start seeing a few Mansions get
damaged this could be very cathartic
for people and I'm not saying that this
should happen but everybody really wants
some Revenge because the recession's
coming you can feel it you can feel it
now it's going to people are starting
to you know the layoffs are here and
then following the layoffs will be
some pain and in order to make that okay
if we saw a couple of Montecito Mansions
really get it
it might make us feel better so I'm just
saying there is going to be an upside to
climate change I always try to look for
the positive there is going to be an
upside to uh the the chaotic destruction
it will affect rich people
and that's what you want
it will damage the homes of wealthy now
yes they have other fine yes they can go
other place sure but just as a visceral
image it is nice to see a couple of rich
people's horses drown
not that you have a prop but you know
like the idea maybe not even drown but
Waist Deep if you see a Montecito Ranch
and the horses are ways deep
and you see people panicking Harry and
Megan ordered to evacuate Montecito
Mansion amid deadly California floods
this is what we want this is what we
want this is good seeing rich people
have to flee their homes because of
fires and flooding makes people that
don't have money a little happy and
isn't that what everything's about at
the end of the day is people just being
a little happy
so that's what I think I'm very bullish
on weather I'm bullish on extreme
weather I am as as a unifying thing in
our society I am bullish on extreme
weather and in fact I think we should
have more of it and if we can't if it's
not happening naturally manufacture it
allaharp all of the conspiracy harp
which I haven't looked into too much but
it's the government controls the weather
conspiracy if we can manufacture this
every now and then let's do it
because I think this will be good for
all of us long term our next partner is
athletic greens I take ag1 by athletic
Koreans literally every day I gave 81 a
try because I wanted better gut health
increased energy immune system support
hated taking pills vitamins and wanted a
supplemental that actually tastes great
I take ag1 in the morning before making
my coffee starting my day and it makes
me feel Unstoppable makes me feel like
I'm on that drug from Limitless who
needs those epic you got ag1
I like the way my body feels
I mean you know so many people their
supplemental routines there's so many
vitamins it's so complicated but what
you can do with ag1 is amazing it's just
one supplement that accomplishes goals
from taking all of these things it's
been part of millions of mornings since
2010 ag-1 gives you increased energy and
mood support making it easy to live your
best life it's an all-in-one formula it
makes it easy it covers all your
nutritional bases every scoop is packed
with 75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients of the highest
quality that give me major benefits I
cut and mood support boosted energy and
even healthier looking skin hair and
nails my age you want to deliver to me
every month so it's been super easy to
make it a daily habit I also get the
single serving travel pack so I never
have to miss a day I just mixed a powder
in the ice cold and I drink the first
thing each morning that's it they do on
taking good care of my body each day is
really that simple
if you're looking for an easier way to
take supplements athletic creams is
giving you a free one year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to
athleticqueens.com Tim Dillon that's
athletic careers.com Tim Dillon check it
out
um the amount of people on this diet
drug now is epic has and we've talked
about it on the patreon ozampic is the
dot is the drug for type 2 diabetes and
every and I didn't know I didn't
understand how this drug worked by the
way and I I started reading articles
about it and I spoke to some people on
it it's actually you have a chemical
revulsion to food when you take ozempic
like if you take goes up which is a shot
it's a syringe it's a shot
and what happens is you actually become
disgusted
with the idea of food you're actually
like repulsed by the idea of food you
want to you start throwing up if you eat
too much you start throwing up you start
like heaving I have friends that say
they it's it's hard like they can't even
get food down it they it's like you know
a drug that you would give to somebody
you know there are these drugs that for
example make alcohol make your body not
tolerate alcohol and it's a way to fight
alcoholism where it just it's a drug
that makes you basically go I am uh you
know I'm no longer getting any of the
benefits of alcohol and this is what
ozempic does to people with food it's
like
um you know it makes you look at Food uh
the way that some people you know would
look at a drug
like heroin where you look at it and you
go I would never do that get that away
from me keep that away from me and my
family I don't want to live in community
now the problem is it is necessary for
Life Food you have to eat
and there's people that aren't really
eating they're taking a bite or two and
then they're going and vomiting in the
bad this is what his epic is you you
take a bite or two of food and then
you're like okay enough for me and
um obviously it's now there's a shortage
of the medication that's in those epic
because everybody with type 2 diabetes
is like what the [ __ ] is rich people in
Hollywood not me yet rich people in
Hollywood are able to take this [ __ ]
they're able to get it their Beverly
Hills doctors will write prescriptions
for this medication that was for people
with type 2 diabetes which by the way
isn't that the one you give to yourself
anyway like isn't that the one that
you're kind of responsible for you
weren't born with it you acquired it so
it's kind of like hey man everybody
we're on what's like if you have type 2
diabetes you gave it to yourself you got
it
so if you no longer have the medication
to fix it it you like to now rich people
in a rich fat people and poor fat people
are having like a little Civil War over
this drug of zempic and this drug of
zempic is really becoming like the hot
weight loss drug Remy Bader went on this
drug who was a
um she's a plus size model she's like a
curvy model
and she talks about this she goes on the
drug and I guess she has some success on
the drug afterwards she just complete
she stops taking it okay
here's what happened she stops taking
ozempic Tick Tock star Remy Bader says
stopping his epic Mater Benji didn't get
so much worse
she stops taking this drug which by the
way you can't do you're not able to stop
it if you start ozempic you cannot stop
ozempic you're in you're in and all the
Kardashians around this epic most of
Hollywood is on his epic all the people
that claim that they are you know
incredibly healthy because of lifestyle
choices and trainers
maybe but a lot of them are on drugs
lycosempec they're on drugs and they
have doctors that write prescriptions
for drugs
um Bader Remy Bader she's goes on those
epic she stops she starts mauling taco
trucks like something out of a horror
movie she's just like a zombie except
you know she's not going for human flesh
you know but she's out there saying I'm
binge eating now like nothing I have
ever done before in my life
because I've stopped taking us epic I am
I am I am out there trying to kill
people to eat now because Bader who's
known for her realistic clothing hauls
on Tick Tock has been vocal about her
experience with binge eating disorder
I saw a doctor and they were like it's
100 because you want on a zepik she said
the impact going off the medication had
on her quote it was making me think I
wasn't hungry for so long I lost some
weight
I didn't want to be obsessed with being
on it long term I was like I bet the
second I get off
I'm gonna get starving again
and she did
as soon as she stopped taking a snapback
it the ferocity came back she just
wanted to eat so you got to be careful
with these drugs I know they seem like
um
they seem like things that are shortcut
it's the
but I'm telling you right now you are
if you get off these drugs you become so
much
more like it's like you basically
putting on a mask you're putting on
contacts where every food you see is
[ __ ] it's all [ __ ] looks like [ __ ]
people bring a porterhouse to the table
or shellfish Tower or a big bowl of
pasta it all looks and smells like [ __ ]
you can't imagine eating it the fact
that other people are eating it makes
you sick and then you take the stop
taking these epic you take the glasses
off it's no longer [ __ ] and you go huh
and then you're like you remember that
you haven't eaten and you're like
and that's bad so I don't know what's
gonna happen
um you know I think that you know people
are always looking for the shortcut and
this is certainly a really good shortcut
um but uh I I I I I feel for this woman
who is now um a danger to herself and
others
when she got off this medication
she's like going around Mall food courts
like a like a ravenous animal she's like
a dog that has been chained up in an
empty Warehouse finally smelling a steak
and this is what's gonna happen
um if you keep taking this [ __ ] you know
I mean I
but I will take it
and it will work because I won't get off
it that's the thing about me is I won't
get off it I I don't this dumb [ __ ] you
don't get off it you stay on it
it's like when you make a lifestyle
choice you you go in
you you choose it but she was also
getting afraid she's like if I'm not the
curvy model what am I
you know if she becomes gaunt and bony
and
Bluetooth is amazing everyone I know
takes blue chill whether you're having
sex or not a bunch of guys might just
get in a car and want hard dicks and
there's nothing wrong with that
I love blue chew I've taken and
everyone's taken it you can take them
anytime day or night you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever an opportunity
Rises the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within 10 days the best
part it's all done online so and here's
the thing you having a birthday party
show off the [ __ ]
take Bluetooth and show your dick to
your family and friends people have to
start showing their [ __ ] to more people
the reason that they're not is because
you're not getting all that blood in
there go to Bluetooth
remember the days when you weren't
always ready to go don't be the guy that
says I don't need it
be the guy that says [ __ ] I have it
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
I'm prepared and Ship Direct to your
door in a discreet package the best part
folks it's all done online
no visits to the doctor's office no
awkward conversations no waiting in line
at the pharmacy you don't have to go
into your doctor go my I have problems
with my dick
you can go online and tell a stranger
that who may or not be may or may not be
a doctor
the thing about blue shoes they want to
help you have better sex discover your
options bluetooth.com chew it and do it
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use our promo code TD at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code TD to receive
your first month free blue Beauty
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring this podcast I
absolutely
I've been with Bluetooth for years
Bluetooth has been such an integral part
of my family and and and I'm so happy
you know
putting you know we all were worried
about uh people in my family you know
that were diagnosed with Ed and this was
hard for us to go through as a family
and we finally found blue true and it
really changed people's lives so
thank you Bluetooth for giving us the
power to dream again
uh um this new movie came out called the
menu which is really really funny and it
parodies
this restaurant not overtly but this
restaurant called noma in Copenhagen
where the chef Renee roseppi it's the
hardest reservation to get in the world
Noma is a um a restaurant in uh Denmark
in Copenhagen and Renee rodzepi is a guy
that really pioneered this type of
um style of cooking where it was like
foraging where you would you know take
local ingredients that were grown in and
around the restaurant and utilize them
this is a guy you know that kind of
reinvented Nordic Cuisine he was like
you know I think he was using ants as
salt at one time like ants because they
had they tasted like salt and he was
using ant it was amazing and I'm trying
to get a reservation here before it
closes it's closing in in 2024.
because again it's more of the war on
the rich
because people are angry that people are
so rich that as the world is burning
down they can go to nice places and eat
because it's you're dominating
you know as you know he had a dish go to
noma's duck dish people did not like
this
they didn't like this he had a duck dish
where he basically
he went a lot of chefs are going he went
too far because what he basically did
was he served you a decapitated duck
this is the head of a dock
and what he's doing is he's saying
[ __ ] this doc I'm
we're rich
that's what he's saying
it's not about food
what bigger lobsters the meat is tougher
you know why they're better it's it's
about power it's not about so what Renee
rodzepi is saying here with this is that
this duck had a family and I don't give
a [ __ ]
just like those people in Yemen
now if if Renee reads Epi at NoMa could
serve you a yemeni child he would
he would serve you a yemeni child and it
would look exactly like that and people
would eat it
this restaurant no Mom
is a restaurant that's about local
ingredients
and but it's also about incredibly
because this is food called food and I I
have witnessed food culture and I was
and I've been a part of it
no offense
and I've seen it I've seen the growth of
the tasting menu I've eaten in La
bernadin when I was a child my father
took me there when I was in seventh
grade he took me to the bernadin and
then he took me to Phantom of the Opera
and then he took then he let me he
brought me to a businessman's house and
he made me suck him off and it was the
best birthday that I ever had but I had
been going to these restaurants these
tasting menus uh for a very long time
and I have an appreciation for fine
dining and they they've gotten more
elaborate as time goes on and and the
menu does a great job making fun of this
stuff the the stories that are being
told about the food the stories that the
ingredients tell about the area food is
about race and about class like the new
writer and the I forget it's maybe the
San Francisco San Francisco Chronicles
always writes about food and class and
you know about what is you know I mean
AOC said something about like Yuka or
something like certain vegetables are
racist or whatever but this idea idea
that uh you know really wealthy people
are they have they have the opportunity
that other people don't have a lot of
people say why are people fat well they
live in food deserts meaning they can't
get good food they wake up and it's Taco
Bell or McDonald's or Burger King that's
it they don't get good produce no Mom
like most good things in life is a
little bit of a lie and the LIE of Noma
is that it's about the environment and
it's about the vegetables but what it
really is about is some people having
more than others because it restricts
those good things the environment it
restricts them and it hands them
rightfully so to a small group of people
that can appreciate them because when I
say he uses ants you go that's gross
answer gross
pizza's good I want more beef you
shouldn't be allowed in Norma you
shouldn't even be allowed in Denmark you
shouldn't be allowed in Copenhagen the
nordics with their beautiful white
bodies not that it's a racial thing they
shouldn't even have to be near you
they're hairless gorgeous
adonis-like physique they shouldn't
they're all swimmers they'll have
swimmers build it's not too much it's
not like we have where it's like people
are just clumps of muscle you know they
have a nice evenly distributed physique
because they eat [ __ ] like this they eat
fish and tiny little potatoes and nobody
cares about anything you're all somewhat
depressed and they all live by canals
but what's nice about restaurants like
Noma
is that it allows people to truly go in
there and feel like kings and queens but
in like a really nice modern way where
they're like hey you know we're telling
the story of our of our of our
environment so noma's closing and Noma
has said now get up noma's statement
when they were closing it what they're
basically saying what they're basically
saying is that
in order to
Noma is closing because
somebody said this
um The Conspiracy people are going Noma
is closing because it's labor practices
are unsustainable
interesting well because they had
interns I think they weren't paying
their interns or something
um but Noma put out a statement
um and they basically said we have to
evolve
um what we're doing right now which is
serving like an 18 course menu to the
wealthiest people in the world we've
been guilted
and we have to stop and now this guy
Renee red zeppe who's exactly what a
chef should be a psychopath lunatic who
wants to murder
and that's good he's been cocked and
he's now making cheeseburgers for slobs
I mean I'm like so I really want to go
to this restaurant before it closes it
to me it's like it's so it's an endless
war on greatness it's an endless war so
to continue being Noma we must change
dear guest colleagues in France winter
2024 will be the last season of Noma as
we know it we are beginning a new
chapter Noma 3.0
in 2025 a restaurant is transforming
into a giant lab a pioneering Test
Kitchen dedicated to the work of food
Innovation blah blah blah they're going
to come up with products there and sell
them in the next phase we will continue
to travel and search for new ways to
share our work our our goal is to create
a lasting organization dedicated to
groundbreaking work and food but also to
redefine the foundation for a restaurant
team a place where you can learn you can
take risks you can grow they have been
guilted into this
no one likes success people hate it and
this man who had the guts to say let's
serve people animals that are not only
cooked but humiliated
let's humiliate this duck let's not only
cook it let's denigrate it let's chop
its head off and let's put it on the
table and where you can imagine it
having a family and you eat it well like
there's something about that he had the
balls to do this and there's something
really truly beautiful about that making
people feel like they're in charge of
nature
for a small window before nature comes
and kills all of us but that's what Rene
was doing he's like here's all this
nature and isn't it great and that's all
ours it's ours if you had the
reservation uh which is very hard to get
but now people are criticizing this man
for this and I think it's disgusting
Noma was about it was the last time in
our history that we were going to
control nature the Flora the fauna it
was the last time we were going to be
able to sit like kings and queens and
eat everything look at all this
beautiful Bounty around us [ __ ]
sustainability [ __ ] everything eat it
delectably put it in our mouths eat it
before the coming Ice Age
it's the last thing we have left now
you're seeing as the weather gets worse
as climate gets worse as inequality
worsens as all of these things happen
restaurants like normal are going to say
I remember after 9 11. in New York City
when a lot of French restaurants seem to
be in bad taste for two reasons number
one the French were little they weren't
exactly on board with our Middle East uh
genocide after 9 11 which was kind of
weird of them
um so people were spilling out French
wine in the street we were calling
french fries Freedom fries but also this
idea of having like a three-hour tasting
menu in a very opulent palatial setting
when uh 3 000 of your fellow citizens
had just been seared for lack of a
better word uh was disgusting it was
grotesque people said so that's when the
Green Market started coming into New
York City dining uh people like Tom
colicchio uh started talking about Green
markets and like all the restaurants
became raw materials it was wood it was
brick it was exposed steel beams and it
was different it was not that you know
pretend things got real after 9 11
things got real and people were like oh
maybe the way we go out the way we enjoy
ourselves should be reflective of the
changes culturally that are happening
that were brought on by this horrible
event that made things more real almost
over nine now with Noma you have a man
who for the last decade or you know
thereabouts has been able to
you know show people that you know the
best of nature it has to be tamed
nature cannot exist without being tamed
so he tames nature the animals the
plants and he brings it to you in the
most amazing way a former Noma intern
describes his time at the restaurant to
the financial times as as a as akin to
being kidnapped from Life due to the
grueling schedule this is now the
Revenge of the losers so the losers are
going to come out I didn't have the time
he's a genius
he's a gene you're decapitating Ducks
he's a genius the man's a genius he's a
genius you dumb American [ __ ] or
copenhagen-ish [ __ ] whatever same [ __ ]
Denmark [ __ ] you lazy [ __ ] you're all
lazy did you Scandinavians are so
[ __ ] lazy there is a word in Denmark
I forgot what it is that basically means
don't stand out like there's a word in
like nordiculture that means like enough
already with your special things blend
in blend the [ __ ] in here's one guy that
dared really to show people that the
most Royal and Regal you will feel is is
taking these precious things that you
see all around you and putting them in
your body eating them
and he's been guilted by Communists and
by Hollywood and by the worst
degenerates that have ever lived and
they're trying to ruin their ruining
these and I haven't even gotten to go
yet and I wanted to go and this is one
of my they closed a bully in Spain from
an Adria's restaurant where he did
Molecular Gastronomy he'd take things
and make them into gases and potions and
he'd be like look that was an orange now
it's a little ball of gel and they
closed that restaurant okay and Noma was
my Mount Everest I'm gonna try to get it
because I'm not I'm gonna stop eating in
restaurants this year for the majority
of the year
um while I do my um
ozempic cleanse and they were they're
going to put me into the body of a a
small uh child that was killed in the
Chicago Fire I spoke to the person who
did Kardashian Chloe I spoke to the same
Necromancer they're going to put me into
the body of a child where I can be
reincarnated because I have money now so
they'll reincarnate me into the body of
a child that died um in their in the
Triangle factory fire and maybe in New
York I don't know but this is what I
because the body has to be completely
charred The Necromancer is explaining it
to me I don't know but the body has to
be completely charred and then I could
you could the soul could be
reconstituted it's not a big deal but it
starts with this epic you you prepare
with those epic and then you are
reincarnated into the body of um someone
else but my point is that I've always
wanted to go to Noma this is a
fascination of mine I took to Sam Talent
who opened for me the great hilarious
Sam Talent go by his book
um and and I would say Samuel we gotta
go to Noma nomenoma Renee where's Epi
Nazis knots in the whole the staff they
fear Him in there and and listen because
listen
you know folks it's a war it's a war
it's a war
being fought right now and people that
want mediocrity to win are in the lead
people that want failure to win are in
the lead and
I don't know what to tell you I don't
know what to tell you but listen people
go oh I don't have a life because I'm a
Noma and I feel like it's been kidnapped
from my life what the [ __ ] were you
gonna do anyway Hans what were you gonna
[ __ ] do anyway
this is a genius he's he's jumping the
heads of ducks
he's doing things with vegetables you've
never even seen this man is is allowing
the people who've ruined the planet to
ruin it just a little bit more before
the planet turns on the planet is just
turning on us all don't you want to have
one last [ __ ] you to the planet don't
you want to have one last middle finger
up piss on the [ __ ] don't you want to
just run through the Brazilian
Rainforest with a [ __ ] flame torch
just before
it's over fully for us and that's what
normal is about to be Noma was the about
total dominance
over the natural world before it kills
us but like Renee rodzepi now has been
bullied I'd love to have him on the show
please reach out to me come on and they
made this movie The Menu which is
hilarious and lovely but it's about this
crazy chef and I love it I think it's
great it's a great movie
um but you know I think and they don't
know if it's ynoma closed or why I
didn't close or whatever but at the end
of the day this this very and you know
this new thing now where it's like
really uh tasting menus where we procure
these very expensive rare ingredients
and serve them as wealthy people there's
something inherently wrong with this
will you stop
what about these clubs where people go
out and they spend
tens of thousands of dollars on booze so
they could go to a VIP lounge and they
could stand there in a club that's okay
that's okay but somehow a restaurant
we're a genius
humiliates
the natural world in front of you abuses
it [ __ ] mushrooms in the face
molests ducks
there's something wrong with that
well that's my that's my take on it I'm
sad as closing and I hope to get a
reservation before it's done because it
does signify to me it's the end of an
era you know that era of fine dining
that era of
um you know total utter and abuse of the
natural world which is so integral to a
great dining experience you really have
to uh humiliate things that should
there's just nothing you have to rip
things out of the ground you have to
cook them you have to kill things you
have to take clams and scallops and this
and that you have to do it this is what
the Native Americans believed the Native
Americans believe that all of these
things were for their benefit and
somehow we've gotten away from that
these vegan freaks are out there saying
that you know oh you know
we don't need to be the Native Americans
would use every part of the animal this
was the thing for the coat and then they
would eat it and then they'd make the
necklace and people you know and we've
gotten away from that now where we think
that like if we dominate the natural
world at all we've done something
horrible but I'm saying it's too late to
make peace with the Earth so we need to
[ __ ] it up a little more right before
the Earth comes for its great Revenge
and that's why
um I'm sad about the closing of Noma the
greatest restaurant may be of all time
in Copenhagen Denmark an unimportant
place that no one it's the only reason
anyone even thought of Denmark is NoMa
the only reason the truly wealthy people
went to Denmark was to eat at NoMa and
it's sad to me that uh this man uh you
know the NFL playoff picture is locked
in and my go-to place for Wild Card
round action is draftking Sportsbook I
love betting it's so important to me
everyone I love loves betting and here's
the reality the NFL is where people bet
this is the season and this is where
people are making money but you need
somewhere that you trust with great
benefits and NFL uh I love the draftking
sports book you know to kick off the
road to Super Bowl 57 new customers can
get in for just five bucks and get 200
and free bets instantly I mean imagine
that imagine walking in in this
somewhere and spending five dollars and
getting two hundred dollars back that
never happens anywhere it's never
happened and it's happening now right
with draftking Sportsbook all new and
existing customers can get a no sweat
bet each day the Wild Card round this
weekend just place any NFL bet of your
choice and if it loses you'll get a free
BET back up to ten dollars action's so
good wipe at NFL playoffs anywhere else
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code Tim Dillon
t-i-m-t-i-l-l-o-n new customers can bet
five dollars on the NFL and get 200 and
free bets instantly I I can't in my head
that I can't even I can't even make
sense of it in my head until you give
them five dollars and they give you 200
and free bets instantly
it did
are they like Jesus Christ it's so
generous to me
it's so generous go to DraftKings
Sportsbook I'm telling you use this
service they don't even care about
making money they care about you see I'm
back manfreda started a stub stack
to defend himself
and uh Sam backmanfried of course uh the
leader of FTX dethroned because of the
rampant anti-Semitism in America uh he
wrote an article on his sub stack and
he's like
I don't steal fawns and I certainly
didn't stash away billions he said ftx's
us is fully solvent and always has been
he wrote of the company's American
Division saying that quote ridiculous
here's the thing Sam talk about the cult
talk about dude your sub Stacks is gonna
it's gonna be boring talk about the sax
call go into that tell us about how it
feels like to be betrayed by this [ __ ]
like you have to make it a little more
fun than just a like an oh like you're
oh you're telling people that it's
actually not that bad which I love which
is kind of funny he's like it's actually
things are actually fine I've been
arrested it's a kind of a mistake
and as soon as I show everyone
I'll find it it's like bankman freed
wrote in the subject post that he was
seeking to set the record straight with
testimony he was set to give the house
Financial Services committee on December
13th unfortunately the Department of
Justice moved to arrest me the night
before preempting my testimony with an
entirely different news cycle he wrote
of his arrest in the Bahamas
never in my career have I seen such a
complete failure of corporate controls
and such a complete absence of
trustworthy financial information
and this is uh
the people that are saying that Sam
packman freed is a liar
and that he will be
um
you know convicted and he will be he
will go down but bang with freed is now
saying that uh on his sub stack that
actually thinks and we're gonna follow
this trial closely we're going to follow
it closely because you know at the end
of the day I um you know I think this
could represent the oh the Bitcoin is up
a little bit bitcoin's up a little bit
Logan Paul has released a video which I
think he's trying to do the right thing
by those people saying he made a little
bit of a whoopsie
and bitcoin's now at 20 784 so it is
starting to creep back up our has
Bitcoin hit a bottom or are people like
you know all these exchanges have gone
out of business it's suffered all this
bad news but at the end of the day is
Bitcoin going to climb back up
I remember in the height of Bitcoin
there were all these ideas you know with
nfts that there was going to be secret
restaurants nft and I was really excited
about this nfts it would get you into
secret restaurants
you know and that nobody would be able
to get into exclusivity is not a
horrible thing it's not the worst thing
um there's worse things than that if
there's worse things than people going
out to dinner and you you can go to Noma
and be poor you just have to make
choices and stop giving your kids
everything
takes from them and give to yourself and
you can fly to Copenhagen and go to Noma
it really depends on what you've got
Foodies have gone there they're not all
rich it's just something nice there is
something to me about this idea that
Excellence is wrong and that Excellence
has to be destroyed and that everything
good has to be common I'm telling you
man this will be society's going to get
very ugly very quickly if this across
the board is embraced that everything
good has to be common and that
attractive people are the anime rich
people are the anime
um 18 course tasting menus are the enemy
they are not the enemy in fact they are
your friend sitting in a restaurant and
having 18 plates of
you know endangered animals and plants
brought to you is
ideal
it's lovely it shows that you've done
this planet the way you should do it
okay and this idea that across the board
that everything has to be common
everything's a cheeseburger we all love
a cheeseburger we all love a a sloppy
slice of pizza we all love a a 3 A.M
disgusting of a [ __ ] with a an old flame
at a bar or something everybody loves
the common things but we we must strive
for better things for great things for
things that mean something
you know and I think that as a society
right now unfortunately we seem to be
embracing this narrative that just
because it's only for a few people it's
bad and that's not true
not everybody's going to be able to
appreciate Noma not everyone's going to
be able to appreciate anything
so why are we restricting uh
you know the people that can appreciate
things from from enjoying them so
someone else better open something and
it better be more ostentatious than Noma
it better be more expensive more
exclusive harder to get in
really really poor taste I'm talking
about people paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars for everybody maybe
it's on a boat
maybe it's not tied to the laws of any
country you know I don't know I'm just
spitballing but I'm saying that like we
can't completely go to war
on the specific
in favor of the general it's it's ugly
it's it's base not based base bad
it's low rent it's not good don't shame
people
on the basis there should be no shaming
don't know my shame don't tasting men
you shame
people
the same way you don't want a fat shape
don't tasting men you shame don't wealth
shame don't privilege shame if you can't
get on a plane and go to Noma that's
[ __ ] your thing
not everybody has to [ __ ] you know
and this guy Renee red red zeppy Renzo I
don't care what his last name is I know
that I'm pronouncing it it's fine I
believe it's red zeppy red and zeppy but
but he
he fully Revel look at this man all this
guy's thought about since he was a child
is having the best restaurant in the
world look at look in his eyes close up
on those eyes look at this man's eyes
he's not even in his own body he's no
longer in his own like every person
who's successful he is somewhere else he
is in a prison of his success and he
will only um be let out of that when he
sheds his Earthly form
and don't you want to eat it that right
you want to eat this poor guy is going
to make burgers now he's gonna make
[ __ ] Burgers he's gonna be nice to
people why would you like what do you
like we could put anything on your
burger you want is that the way you want
to go out you [ __ ] freaks is that the
way you want Society to end like like
him violent Geniuses having to be
neutered and made to make cheeseburgers
for the sloths
it's not right
so we hope that the weather in
California gets better we are cautiously
optimistic about that I do see the
benefit of a little
unease and I think you do too now that
I've explained it but we don't want it
to be we don't want to go overboard so
there you have it there are some
thoughts about what's going on this week
Tim dilloncomedy.com we have all the
dates up there for tickets patreon.com
the Tim Dillon Trail for bonus content
uh the episode of Joe Rogan was a lot of
fun
um and we will see you guys on the road
thank you very much and let us hope that
if this weather doesn't get better let's
hope the destruction in people's lives
brings happiness uh to others that are
watching it on TV